Now that we talked about doing
reinforcement learning in a POMDP
setting, we're actually now going to
talk about a much weirder combination.
We're going to talk about how we can
think of reinforcement learning as
actually being itself a POMDP.
>> Okay.
>> This is an area that
is often referred to as
Bayesian Reinforcement Learning.
The idea is that we're going to keep
a a Bayesian posterior over
possible MDPs that we're in.
And we're going to use that to actually
optimally balance exploration and
exploitations.
We're actually going to
behave optimally and
reinforcement learning becomes planning.
>> Okay, so does it mean we're
going to use Bayes rule?
>> Well I guess technically in that
whenever your compute a posterior,
you're actually doing
something like Bayes rule.
Yeah, but maybe this is not so clear.
Let me try to draw a picture.
So I'm hoping this example might
make things a little bit clearer.
So let's consider a really simple
reinforcement learning problem.
We've got two states, state 1 and
state 2, two actions a black one and
a, I don't know, purplish kind of one.
And if we were doing reinforcement
learning in this environment, and
you were say the reinforcement learner,
what would you do?
Let's say we're in state 1,
Would it be better to do purple or
black?
>> I don't know.
>> Okay so then what would you do?
>> I'd pick one of them.
>> All right, so
let's say you pick black and
then we would observe a transition.
And ultimately we can sort
of build out a model or
use queue learning or something
like that to work out the values.
So what I'd like to do is actually
try to have you think about this
like a POMDP.
And I think a simpler
way to show you that
would be instead of imagining
all possible MDPs this could be,
let's just pretend it comes
from of a small finite set.
Okay, are there any small
sets that aren't finite?
>> No.
>> Good,
then I think we're on the same page.
>> All right, then I agree with you.
So here's the set that I had in mind,
we've got three possible worlds
that we're in A, B and C.
So these are three possible MDPs, right?
>> Okay and they all look exactly the
same to me except where you get reward.
>> Yeah, so it just so happens that
the actions all do the same thing in all
three of these and we know that.
We just don't know where the reward is.
Is the reward something you get for
purple when you go from state 2?
Is it something that you get for
purple from state 1?
Or is it something that you get from
taking the black action from state 1?
And we don't know.
Now if you had to solve this
reinforcement learning problem,
it's kind of a reinforcement
learning a problem, right?
You're in some state you get to
see what state you're in, 1 or 1.
You can try actions black or purple.
And what you're trying to do is actually
figure out how to maximize reward.
But now that it's just
a finite set of possibilities,
we can think about this like a POMDP.
>> Sure and in fact, I think this
one's pretty straightforward.
If I'm in state 2,
I know what I should do.
>> And what is that?
>> I should take the purple action.
>> And why is that?
Explain.
>> Because I immediately either
get reward for it or I know that I
get reward for being in state 1.
And then when I'm in state 1,
well actually it's not clear
which one I should do.
>> All right, so
let's well let's just do two things.
Let's start off by just tracking belief
states in this because I think that's
already kind of an interesting
problem in and of itself.
What we're thinking about here is
that we're in POMDP with six states.
Often state 1, but
we don't know which MDP were in,
then the belief state is going to
look something like this.
Agreed?
>> Agreed, if this is where we're
starting, we know nothing else, and
we haven't done anything yet,
then we can be in any of those states,
presumably with equal probability.
>> Good, right, so
now the question is, if you were to do
the purple action from here,
what would your expected reward be?
>> My expected the reward
would be one-third.
>> Right, so
if we happen to have been in MDP B,
which we don't know if we are and we
took the action purple, we'd get a one.
If not, then we get zero.
But what also would
happen if we get the one?
What's our new belief state?
>> If we get the one?
>> Yeah.
>> Well then we know that we are in B1.
>> Good, B1, right.
So we're in this state, so
the belief state becomes basically
fully observable at this point.
We know which MDP, we're in.
And we know what state
of that MDP we're in.
And we can just execute
the optimal policy for that MDP,
which in this case, as you might guess,
is just purple all the time.
>> Purple all the time,
purple all the time.
Yeah, I agree.
>> Excellent.
So let's make sure you get this,
we'll do a little quizzy kind of thing.
>> Okay.